famous fleeting are saying it passes and
it doesn't mean anything it just means
that you're recognized by like they know
who you are and they heard something you
did and yeah but when P Diddy had that
song and he came out oh yeah I'll give
you an example so so you know you know
who he is right okay so when did you
know uh so when he was at the height of
his career he's still big and he's still
huge and and but but when he first came
out on the scene do you know what his
first hit was I don't think that was his
first hit I think it was the biggest I
don't think the first big one no no but
it did get a lot of recognition and it
was him watching you yeah he was doing
that Biggie Smalls it was right there
yeah a tribute a tribute to Biggie
Smalls do you know who Biggie Smalls is
no no okay but he was a he was another
rapper who got who got killed the famous
bleeding right and then what you say got
killed he did and and he he you know uh
he sang a uh a song and sampled sting
okay in the song
and and it was one of the stings or the
police's I'll be watching you right yeah
is it I don't think that's what it's
called but what's it called do you know
what it's called does anybody know what
that song's called
yeah yeah it was Diddy I think Faith
Evans
um anyway it was a big hit for him this
is my point my point and it was a big
hit and it was I'll be missing you I'll
be missing you I'm sorry it was a big
hit for him and it's based on uh he was
redoing and sampling uh the sting song
okay and I took her we were watching the
MTV Music Awards and Diddy was singing
this it was like the biggest moment of
the MTV Awards all the young people were
going crazy for it right I think we went
live did we go to the taping I can't
remember and then as a surprise right
sting comes out on stage to play his
part and The Crowd Goes Wild it went
bonkers
my daughter goes who is this guy that's
ruining the song ruining the song the
white guy's ruining the song wait a
minute she didn't even know who he was
no no idea so but that's kind of it now
I do now I do you know whose thing is I
know whose thing is and I like the
police okay uh but but my point is that
that was his song it was amazing that he
joined this young fella to kind of
honor the fact that he was sampling and
doing his song
but this generation didn't know that
song
[Music]